is this your first time yeah it's my
first time [__] so you're from Estonia
uh and so first first time in Asia right
yeah oh wow first time in Asia damn I
mean I when I left it was 16° c yeah so
when I arrived here it was like
34 like got the tail end of the people
said it was so much worse before I was
like what yeah it was what do you mean
it was Yeah Yeah so basically if you
don't know Mudan is basically the reason
most of us here uh exist mud's the
reason why anti exists basically yeah so
we don't edit this podcast we don't also
edit all of my most of my channels yeah
all of them start off with all of them
yeah yeah and then Joey's uh main
Channel as well and uh who else do you
Ed it for uh Sydney AI um some people I
don't know if I should mention okay okay
uh like 10 different people right now
Jesus 10 different people as well now up
as well damn basically I think it's only
my channels pretty much free to preface
this is not you doing this Sol no no
yeah yeah yeah I got a very dedicated
team team behind me who are probably
more talented than me so how so how many
so you kind of built like um like your
own I guess like editing company was it
or like organiz when the [__] did that
start yeah cuz I think I came in when
you were just editing for trash taste I
was like oh mud's editing everything
then he started for Conor and then
started for Sydney and then Conor launch
a second Channel and I'm like how is
mood keeping up with all this when uh
when did it happen yeah so I wanted to
do video editing as a full-time job and
it took like a long time to get off I
was like barely earning any money for
the first two years but then suddenly I
guess through recommendations people
were like oh he's doing a good job let
me recommend him to another person and
finally I had like three people I think
you and Connor and somebody else and it
was like sometimes it was easy cuz it
was like one video a week but sometimes
you'd be like Oh I'm going to America
for a month here are four vide that need
to be done and it would like accumulate
together with you guys so I was like
okay I cannot keep on working 300 hours
a month so I was like okay let me find
somebody else and thankfully uh my first
another editor was Danny the editor uh
he I found him through a mutual and
pretty much it took like 6 months to
teach him up but he's like a right-and
manra really talented and uh then like
half a year later both of us were doing
300 hour work
months so how it works like that huh
yeah and then I realized okay we need to
keep on expanding so now I have a huge
team behind me I think in Estonia like
in my own company I have Danny I have
mudam who's U my partner as well there
another mudam
mudam so you're Mudan and there's also
mudam yeah okay like a female
Mudan
mudam yeah I mean she actually LS uh
does them trash tape least uh like um
scene changes oh she's also she's also a
professional camera operator in Estonia
like sports shoots and stuff oh cool so
she has background in it so how many
people do you have now like in your
company I have four who I've hired like
in my company per say which means I pay
like for their holidays for for health
and stuff and around 10 Freelancers
plusus four God damn it's cool that
you've gone from just being solo to that
yeah so kind of crazy to have that kind
of ambition I think a lot of people
would be like okay this is this is scary
it is is so horrible every day I wake up
and sweat I'm like oh my God is this the
downfall today yeah cuz I was going to
ask uh you are human right you I just I
just want to check that you've not
you're see if I you're not like the t00
like you're wearing you're wearing a
wristband that checks your vital I'm not
too sure to be honest if you don't know
like mud or like you are the most
efficient human being I've ever met in
my life to the point where sometimes I
question if you have not like
pre-programmed yourself every morning to
be the most efficient thing you could be
I I remember one one uh time where I was
like yeah this guy's not human was uh it
was ax a few years ago where you were
there and we were just chilling out in
the hotel room um oh the hotel lobby or
something and we were just like chatting
and all that kind of stuff and then just
like as this conversation is going
between Mudan myself and like a couple
of other people Mudan just like pulls
his phone out and just starts like doing
something and I thought you were like
playing a game and I looked over and you
had mirrored your computer back at home
onto your mobile and you were editing a
video on your phone yeah I think it was
because trash taste like meie needed uh
the outro cinematic to be like longer or
something yeah and it had to be done
within half an hour you just doing it on
your
phone this guy's not human it takes a
while it's like 10 times longer on the
phone but it's [__] it's 10 times longer
yeah so like I I want to ask what is
your advice for like efficiency hack how
how does how does how do you how did you
minmax your life yeah how did you minmax
your life as much as possible addiction
just be addicted to one thing do it just
stick to that that's the only
explanation I think a lot of a lot of
the times when um people have well
YouTubers and they work with Ed it's
kind of like this honeymoon period where
it's really fun and it's exciting to
edit for for someone new and then it
kind of you know becomes a lot more like
okay there's a deadline can we make sure
we meet it and it becomes like that but
I guess yeah you it's never been like
that for you which is so how did you I
guess that's one thing I've always
wanted to ask you is like how did you
get into like video editing like where
where does that passion come from well
uh I don't know about a lot of people
but pretty much until I was like 17 16 I
had no ambition in life like I didn't
know what I wanted to do you just
described every teenage yeah exactly
people ask you oh what do you want to be
when you grow up you're like it worker I
don't [__] know yeah uh but well when
I was 13 I was really like panic mode
looked around my room like what what
should my purpose in life be show my PSP
I saw my PSP collection was like I'm
going to collect all of them okay and
that was for the next 5 years that was
my life's purpose and then I think in
high school they had like um uh cameras
at school mhm and I borrow them for like
uh ex no actually just before that year
I decided to do like um a stop motion
Tetris in with chocolate for some reason
I don't know
why yeah CU like back then the cameras
didn't really shoot film like none of
the phones had videos and I had one
camera at home and it was like uh one of
those old ones that only shot pictures
so I couldn't like shoot video I was
like all right stop motion it is damn
and when I got to school they actually
had cameras you could borrow so I got to
I borrowed a camera and it was really
fun to like think of something and make
it into a reality and then for the next
3 years I pretty much had the camera
like half the time with me
D [__] hell so like we talked about
this before we started recording but
what are you wearing now
like thing yeah cuz I thought it like me
and Conor thought it was a wristwatch at
first and I was like wait a minute I
can't see any numbers on that no this is
a this is a whoop this is uh pretty much
to uh check your uh vitals I guess like
what is a better word to use it we have
it's like dystopian as [__] to say that
you have the same thing you just have a
screen on it it's just steps it's got
steps doesn't it check your pulse uh
yeah it does too yeah does it check your
sleep uh I don't wear it for bed it does
the same thing I just don't have a how
the [__] can you sleep how can you sleep
with it all I don't know I mean I mean
there is there is something ironic about
me being like Oh Yeah it's you're so
dystopian h w no I I I was uh thinking
of getting like a smartwatch and then I
was like I don't want a screen on my
watch so this was the most of the time
if I get buzz like three times in a row
too fast I just like rip it off I'm like
[__] this I'm like I'm like I I used to
wear a smartwatch as well but like just
the like cuz every notification goes to
your wrist right so it's like I don't
want this I just liked it when I it was
just kind of s extra saratoni even
though you don't need this when you go
to the gym or you work out or even if
you do a long walk and you come back
it's like that walk was 700 calories
like damn nice but how true is it uh
probably not true it's probably a little
over generous uh but this one has the
fit B it's [__] anyway it's all
[__] yeah so I mean like this is
this is going to something different now
but so you wanted a smartwatch that
wasn't a smart watch but that could give
you everything that a smartw watch could
give you EX for telling the time yeah
well are you are you trying to optimize
being a human yeah what do you mean okay
yeah he's trying to fit in with the
humans he's like are you trying are you
trying are you trying to become the
perfect human being so to edit better
you need to be healthy oh my God [__]
hell mud if you're tired the day is
going to go to waste you can't get as
much done so you need to be more
productive you need to sleep well you
need to eat well you need to get all
your vitamin so are you being like very
health conscious recently yeah well it's
not like maximizing everything like 100%
but just a bit more I saw you made a
tweet saying like you what happens if
you take like any every vitamin on Earth
was that like a joke tweet or is that
something you've done it I'm taking it
it's still here what the i i i i we
shared a room not too long ago and uh he
had this like Monday Tuesday can I can I
say this he had this Monday Tuesday
Wednesday medicine thing he had two of
them and they were both full of just
various pills
and I was like there was at least 20
pills a day he was taking you're not
human bro and what were you what what is
there like what are you taking 24 okay
24 pills what is what is yes and it's
like a handful like a legit handful of
pills it's nice as like your morning
lunch as well dude
you so what is okay what is what is in
these 24 pills and what are you hoping
to get out of it okay so it's uh basic
vitamins cuz in Estonia you lack
Sunshine a lot so was like vitamin D
deficient so that's a big thing then I
have minerals like I was also cuz okay
don't how do you know if you're vitamin
D deficient okay first of all don't take
pills just cuz you can buy them like I I
did it sounds like when you're have 24
pills you got to be close no no I did a
different blood tests to like first of
all vitamin tests and then mineral tests
yeah I mean vitamin D deficiency is
pretty bad okay where did you get this
done how did this is a place you can do
it yeah maybe I should do it well I'm
just going to go I got to go to hospital
and they give you like blood grades and
stuff yeah yeah but it's not about like
vitamins and stuff and minerals it's
just about like blood Health whatever
means whatever that means it's like a
long time ago uh because I didn't eat
red meat that much cuz I just didn't
want to uh I was very vitamin B12 like
deficient and I would get like insane
headaches and tired and I didn't know
why and then I took the pills and I was
like fine like two weeks
afterwards I mean it sounds smart when
you put it in that perspective but also
sounds kind of bizarre bro you're going
to end up in the [__] like old folks
with like
80 what is it only red meat where you
can get that vitamin or was there some
kind of food you us were like meat is
the best like thing for you didn't want
to just change the diet a little bit you
want to cuz I was kind of dumb like
every day I would eat the same things I
would wake up eat porridge in the middle
of day I'd eat pasta at night I eat rice
with like chicken and that was all cves
that's what all I eat for like two years
straight like only those things yeah I
think I'd get a headache too if I for
two years it was fine I liked it I'm
sure you did but like wait what was the
pasta you plain or like something uh I I
had some uh cheese on it I can see why
you wear the whoop now
bro do you know how expensive f is I'd
be pretty scared as well for my vitals
it was really cheap it was like 50 bucks
a month on was was this before you
became a full-time editor actually no
that checks out there you just do I be
paying you more like are you good like
no when I got uh when I got an actual
job I was like all right in my poast I'm
going to put would like minc meat now
I'm
moving living living good okay we're
eating good tonight we're putting mince
meet in this so personal question have
you always been like conscious about how
optimized you are as a human being or
was this something that happened
naturally as you got more editing jobs
and you kind of like started working
more uh for all of us I'm asking if if
why you look at me like I like I was I'm
you were like like preparing for to say
something I was like I was thinking I
was like yeah I think I do optimize some
things but not like my diet to or which
I probably should optimize I I
definitely think about I I do you anyone
do you anyone do this where you when I
need to do multiple things in the house
I'm always constantly thinking about the
optimal path in order to do everything
and I'm obsessed with it I don't know
why but the problem is is that for a lot
of people they think about the optimal
path but they think about it for way too
long and then don't get any of it done
that just happened that just happened s
go ahead oh uh what was the question
yeah so like were you always conscious
about how optimized your life was uh
kind of it it mostly depends on how like
where I am in life cuz like people can
watch YouTube videos like oh how to
optimize your life and like these like
10 things but that doesn't work cuz you
need to optimize it for yourself
everybody is so different it's not
personalized so even if I find like a
perfect app that works me for that year
like two years later I might move to
something that works for that time in
the beginning when I didn't have like a
team I didn't need Google Calendar I
didn't need like specific
but now that it's like bigger or my life
is different I like change it around
yeah so when did the vitamins like at
which point because okay I 24 [__]
vitamins day when when does the vitamin
AR start so I understand like optimizing
your life getting calendars getting like
a to-do list every day you know I've
done that uh there's a there's like
there's a big step for me from like
trying to optimize some parts of your
life to be like I can take every vitamin
Under the Sun to make sure that my body
is as optimized as possible which you
know is actually a pretty smart thing to
do to become health conscious but that
is a big step I just don't want to be on
a steady diet of pills you know I mean I
assume any other people who do this are
like professional actors who have to get
in like crazy shape or something right
like they like the most insane body
coaches it's not like it's insane I
don't know to srone pills or something
it's like very basic stuff like What
vitamin b c d uh [__] magnesium
calcium selenium you you're not getting
any of this stuff enough not really I
think I think you need to be expanding
maybe your like Diet no I think I think
we probably have deficiencies too but
I'm just like oh man feel tired today
I'll just tomorrow we get fine a couple
coffees and we good you know like half a
year ago I stumbl upon this YouTuber I
was influenced oh okay okay okay called
like Brian Johnson who who looked like
kind of like kind of insane cuz he's
like this kind of a vampire insane rich
person who tries to live forever in a
way I was very skeptical in the
beginning but then there's like he has
like no terior motives like every that
he does or tests is on his website for
free like 100% And I was like okay
that's pretty interesting and I looked
at his statistics and all the pills and
everything and uh like his description
and how he changed his life and I was
like okay well I'm going to try it out
for a month see how it works and after
like 2 weeks my I would say my personal
like feelings increased by like 20% and
my wellbeing sizable change I'm should
try this too and I'll come back uh and
be like man you changed my life yeah
Conor's going to come back to the office
with medicine box I got I got to figure
out who who I got to ask to get these
tests done what do you just get blood
tests hosital do you have a coupon code
yeah you got like a website or something
like you got you got a website got a
code is it like a subscription or
something uh just normal hospitals I
presumably you have to go back to check
up on like how like it's going is there
like what's is there any downsides to
getting like you're probably not a
medical professional but I Assam this
downsides having like too much of
certain vitamins as well yeah yeah I
know like I picked the ones that I
needed not everything that he takes
I designated towards my like diet so
some like half the stuff I'm not taking
some stuff I'm taking CU I did like um
I've done blood tests for a couple years
now to see like how my vitamins are and
pretty much now I just did the mineral
test as well which are pretty expensive
cuz they charge like 20 bucks per one
mineral mhm which is uh wow yeah pretty
insane but I discovered some that I'm
missing for some reason which are like
kind of basic and so I'm just taking
those and uh I think some only last also
for half a year and then I'm going to
stop taking them right right right so
it's not like I'm doing it forever what
what do you think has been like the most
effective with is it the vitamins
absolutely no [__] idea I'm taking
like 20 of
them that's the it just be AER for a weo
as well if it was that's great I don't
care yeah fair enough as long as it
works I mean yeah I think I'd feel
something putting 24 pills in my body
I'd either be floating by the end of it
or I'd be just BS I'd be scared to
swallow stuff for a while